-Welcome back, everybody.
As you know, March Madness
kicks off next week.
This is where we find out who
the best college basketball team
in the country is.
But over on our sister station,
the Steel Network,
they're doing something
a little different.
They have a tournament
to find out
who the best college basketball
mascot is.
It's called March Madness
Mascot Mayhem.
It's pretty intense.
And, actually,
it's on right now.
If I could just switch
the channel -- check this out.
♪♪
>> The Steel Network presents
"March Madness Mascot Mayhem!"
Whoo!
-Yeah! Welcome to March Madness
Mascot Mayhem.
I'm Skeeter Ramsay,
and I'm joined by my partner,
Pat Lefritz.
Pat, we've got a competition
for the ages tonight.
-Well, that's right, Skeeter.
Yeah, w-we're down
to the final four mascots...
-Cuatro left.
-...in this year's tournament.
And the mayhem's about to begin.
-Well, it certainly is.
Now, let's meet the mascots.
Representing Duke University,
it's the Blue Devil.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-From the University
of North Carolina,
it's Rameses!
-Oh, wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
From the University of Miami,
give it up for Sebastian!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-And last but not least,
it's the pride of Virginia Tech.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the HokieBird.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-All right.
That's right, you can feel
the excitement in the air, Pat.
You've got four equally-talented
mascots out there,
but only one will survive.
What are the keys to the game?
-Well, it's going to be
a real nail-biter, Skeeter.
But the mascots have heart.
They've got determination.
You know, one of them
even has a cape. [ Laughs ]
In the end, it's all going to
come down to who wants it more.
-And we're about to find out.
Let's get this party started.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Round one -- flip cup.
-Whoo! Facing off in flip cup,
we've got Rameses
versus the Blue Devil.
The first to flip three cups
wins.
On your mark, get set, go.
[ Whistle ]
-There's no love lost between
these two bitter rivals, Pat.
[ Bell dings ]
Oh, we've got a winner
right there already!
Oh, my goodness.
-Wow!
-Right there's our winner.
-The Blue Devil.
The Blue Devil moves on.
-Duke takes!
-Congratulations, Blue Devil.
-And now it's time to find out
who you'll be facing off
against.
It's time for round two.
-Round two -- dunk contest.
-Whoo! Now, this is
the mascot dunk contest,
with Sebastian going up
against the HokieBird.
The rules are simple.
You each get one dunk,
and the best dunk wins.
-And remember, you'll all be
judged in three areas --
technical precision, difficulty
level, and most importantly,
pizzazz.
-That's right.
Sebastian, you're up first.
Don't be nervous.
Let's see if you've got
some dunk in your trunk.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Whistle ]
-Outrageous!
-Can we see that -- Can we see
that again in slow motion?
He goes up for the air,
he gets a little air, and bang.
And then watch what he does
after this.
This is kind of exciting.
Hey-yo.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a photo flip
right there.
-Wow.
-All right.
It is your turn, HokieBird.
Fly, turkey, fly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Audience ohs ]
-Well, I think it -- I think
it goes without saying.
The winner is Sebastian
with the dunk.
[ Bell dinging,
cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it all comes down to this.
It's time for the final round.
-Final round -- dance off!
-Whoo!
-Our two finalists are --
the Blue Devil.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-Sebastian.
-That's correct.
And may --
may the best mascot win.
And may I also remind you
that pride
is on the line, so bring it.
First up,
we have the Blue Devil.
Whenever you're ready.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's really leaving it all
out there, Skeeter!
-I've never seen anything
like it.
He's tearing up the floor.
Look at that --
-He's become one with the music.
-Yeah, a really great job.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Blue Devil went for it
right there.
A master class in body movement.
What did you think, Pat?
-Outrageous!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-All right.
Sebastian --
Sebastian, you're up.
Let's see what you can do.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoa! I've never seen --
I've never seen anything
like that,
and I've snowboarded down
Mt. Everest in the nude.
Amazing moves out there.
What did you think, Pat?
-Outrageous!
-All right, yeah, exactly.
Pat, it is time to find out who
this year's champion will be.
The winner will be decided
by audience applause.
Is it the Blue Devil?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or is it Sebastian?
[ Louder cheers and applause ]
The winner is Sebastian!
[ Bell dinging ]
Congratulations.
Great job, Sebastian.
Thank you to all of our mascots.
Look for them in this year's
March Madness tournament.
We'll be right back with more
"tonight show" everybody.
Come on back!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪